Der Rasenfunk. Kurzpass. Auf die Jahreshauptversammlung eines Bundesliga-Vereins guckt eigentlich ganz Fußballdeutschland, denn es wird nicht weniger verhandelt als 50 plus 1. Also was ist da passiert bei Hannover 96? Wir wollen es klären mit Tobi von Hannover liebt. Tobi, sei mir gegrüßt. Das finde ich sehr schön, dass du mir zur Verfügung stehst nach einer sehr langen und wie immer erkenntnisreichen Jahreshauptversammlung bei Hannover 96. Vielen Dank dir.
Du weißt, es war tatsächlich, ich glaube, eine Stunde weniger als letztes Jahr. Da sind wir irgendwie erst gegen kurz vor eins aus der ganzen Veranstaltung rausgekommen. Gestern war es dann schon 23.30 Uhr.
Ja, da waren sie noch gnädig mit euch. Es hatte diesmal keine Überlänge. Jeder, der dir auf Twitter folgt, atrunnertobi heißt du dort, der hat schon mitbekommen, dass du da sehr aktiv warst. Du hast schon in den ganzen letzten Jahren immer live getickert und getwittert von der Jahreshauptversammlung. Weil Hannover 96 so im Brennpunkt von vielen Fußballfans in Deutschland steht, dachte ich mir, das ist mir jetzt ein Kurzpass wert. Ich möchte wissen, was ist da passiert? Also Tobi, führ uns mal ein. Um was ging es bei dieser Jahreshauptversammlung? Was waren die wichtigen Themen?
Es war gar nicht... Ich fand es im Opener fast ein bisschen übertrieben, weil es über 50 plus 1 entschieden wurde. So dramatisch ist es eigentlich nicht gewesen. Es war trotz allem...
Aber wir gucken deswegen alle hin, Tobi, das meine ich. Mit Verlaub, Hannover 96 wäre mir die Jahreshauptversammlung sonst eigentlich nicht so wichtig wie in diesem ganzen 50 plus 1-Kontext.
Hier ist immer gute Unterhaltung. Also wenn man ein bisschen Spaß haben will, kann man da sicherlich viel Zeit mit verbringen. Nein, es ging grundsätzlich um mehrere Anträge, die aus der Mitgliedschaft gestellt wurden. Das waren drei Anträge, drei Sachanträge, vier Informationsanträge und ein, und das war das Wichtige an diesem Abend, ein Satzungsänderungsantrag. Das ist ja immer nicht ganz leicht. Brauchste zwei Drittel der Stimmen für. Das wurde letztes Jahr schon probiert. Und das ist dann auch so ein bisschen der Aufhänger der ganzen Geschichte. Letztes Jahr wurde versucht, eine Satzungsänderung zu machen. Das ist gescheitert, auch relativ deutlich. Und es wurde dann so ein bisschen aus der Not heraus ein zweiter Antrag geboren, der wollte, dass der Vorstand bei allen wichtigen Entscheidungen, das heißt konkret bei der Geschichte mit 50 plus 1, dass man diesen Antrag auf Ausnahmegenehmigung stellt, dass der Vorstand dort auf die Mitglieder hört und das nicht in Eigenregie entscheidet. Und da hat man letztes Jahr darüber abgestimmt und da gab es auch ein relativ deutliches Votum dahingehend, ja, der Vorstand soll auf jeden Fall auf die Mitglieder hören und fragen, wenn sowas gemacht wird. Da hat der Vorstand aber nicht gemacht. Und der Vorstand, um den Namen zu nennen, Martin Kind, ist dort sicherlich der, den alle kennen, hat diesen Antrag, wie ich glaube auch alle wissen inzwischen, tatsächlich gestellt und hat sich dementsprechend nicht diesem Mitgliedervotum unterworfen. Und da gab es Richtsverfahren in den letzten Monaten dazu, dass das, ob das denn jetzt alles in Ordnung sei. Dort wurde eigentlich dem Vorstand grundsätzlich Recht gegeben, dass die Entscheidungen, die dort getroffen worden sind, darf der Vorstand alleine treffen, ist in Ordnung.
Trotz dieser Satzungsänderung, also man darf dann gegen die eigene Satzung handeln?
Ne, man darf nicht gegen die eigene Satzung. Also die Satzung wurde letztes Mal nicht geändert, das hat nicht funktioniert. Dafür braucht es eine Zweidrittelmehrheit. Aber die Mehrheit der Mitglieder, ich müsste lügen, 70 Prozent, waren sich einig, dass man durchaus die Mitglieder fragen könnte. Aber es hat nicht gereicht für diese Satzungsänderung. Der Vorstand hat sich nicht dran gehalten an das, was die Mitglieder beschlossen haben. Und da hat man gesagt, okay, dann versuchen wir es dieses Jahr auf einem anderen Weg. Wir wollen, dass in der Satzung direkt drin, jetzt, okay, der Vorstand, das, was die Mitglieder entscheiden, quasi umsetzen muss, also eine Pflicht daraus entsteht. Das ist H-Spalterei, was die Worte angeht in der Satzung. Da wurden auch wirklich nur wenige Kleinigkeiten verändert.
Aber juristisch, ja.
Juristisch wichtig, ja. So war der Plan. Und dafür gab es diesen Satzungsänderungsantrag, der von zwei Personen gestellt wurde, die sich auch beide gestern Abend noch mal vorgestellt haben und auch diesen Satzungsänderungsantrag vorgestellt haben, begründet haben, sehr umfangreich und sehr, ja auch auch verschieden. Also jeder hat so ein bisschen seine Aspekte gemacht. Da war eine Frau, ein Mann und die eine hat es eher auf die persönliche Ebene gezogen, der andere hat es in die Richtung, wir Mitglieder müssen doch zusammen hier die wichtigen Entscheidungen treffen. Ja, in die Richtung ging das. Und das ist natürlich etwas, was der Vorstand nicht möchte. Und dementsprechend hat sich da in den letzten, lass mich lügen, zwei Wochen hat sich das wirklich hochgeschaukelt, hat sich da ein Kampf vor der Jahres-Hopfersammlung ergeben, bei dem beide Seiten ordentlich Feuer gemacht haben, würde ich sagen.
Inzwischen ja fast schon ein Klassiker bei Bundesligisten. Das erlebt man immer häufiger bei so grundlegenden Satzungsänderungen, dass da mit allen Mitteln getrickst wird, auch um zu versuchen, dann die Mehrheiten für sich zu garantieren. Ich erinnere mich an den 1. FC Köln, da gab es einen kostenlosen Hoodie für jeden, der zur Jahreshauptversammlung kommt, mit dem Hintergedanken, dass man vermutet, dass man dadurch ein Publikum anzieht, was eher solchen Änderungen kritisch gegenübersteht und sagt, nee, lassen wir es lieber mal alles beim Alten. Beim VfB Stuttgart gab es ein Trikot. Was gab es bei Hannover 96? Gab es eine schöne Tasse?
Nein, es gab weder Trikots noch Hoodies. Ja, aber pass auf, es gab so die eine oder andere kleine Idee. Man kann das jetzt groß interpretieren, dass das genau mit dieser Intention gemacht wurde. Ich persönlich würde das auch tatsächlich tun. Es gibt sicherlich Leute, die das komplett abstreiten würden. Also auf der einen Seite gab es Tickets für das Spiel gegen Bayern München am kommenden Samstag, also morgen, zu gewinnen.
Sehr sportlich irrelevant, aber gut, ja, interessant.
Es ist so ein kleines Anlocken gewesen, wurde aber auch recht kurzfristig bekanntgegeben. Ich weiß gar nicht, wo sie diese Tickets wieder hergegraben haben. Dann gab es noch ein paar Tickets für das letzte Heimspiel gegen Hertha. Ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt so viele Leute vorgeholt haben, aber das lassen wir an dieser Stelle dann auch mal. Und da ist dann vielleicht das gewesen, was so ein bisschen versteckter war, aber in meinen Augen doch eine ziemlich deutliche Geschichte war. Man hat natürlich versucht, die Mitglieder zu motivieren, dass man die Opposition, ich nenne das jetzt an dieser Stelle Opposition, wir können da vielleicht gleich noch mal so ein bisschen drüber sprechen, dass dieses Wort gar nicht von allen so gerne gesehen ist, dass die Opposition motiviert ist, dass die aktiviert ist, da stand fest, das lief, das lief über Wochen, Monate, die Leute kamen sowieso. Das heißt, der EV, Martin Kind, der Vorstand, hatte jetzt die Aufgabe, möglichst viele andere Mitglieder zu motivieren, zu dieser Versammlung zu kommen und abzustimmen. Wie macht man das? Man macht das über die Abteilungsleiter der einzelnen Sparten. Wir haben 16 Sparten bei Hannover 96 und hat dann sich die Wahl zum Sportler des Jahres ausgedacht. Gab es noch nie? Wir haben noch nie den Sportler des Jahres von Hannover 96 gewählt, dieses Jahr erstmalig. Wozu führt das? Jede Sparte präsentiert einen Sportler, der dann quasi diese Sparte repräsentiert. Der hat sogar noch einen Paten aus der Bundesligamannschaft gekriegt. Videos wurden gedreht, vorgetrommelt. So und dann geht der natürlich dahin und dann bringt er vielleicht auch noch seine drei besten Kumpels vom Tischtennis mit oder vom Dart oder von welcher Sportart auch immer. Und so hat man versucht, möglichst viele Mitglieder, die vielleicht gar nicht so viel mit der Profifußballabteilung am Hut haben, an diesem Tag in diese Versammlung zu bringen.
Hat es denn funktioniert? Hattet ihr mehr Teilnehmer als sonst auf den Jahresaufversammlung?
Ja, wir wachsen ja quasi exponentiell. Du hast es vorhin gesagt, ich mache das schon seit ein paar Jahren. Ich glaube, das ist das fünfte oder das sechste Mal in Folge, dass ich da dabei bin. Die ersten Male fand das im VIP-Bereich in der damals noch, wie ist die Arena? Ach ist auch egal, im Niedersachsen-Stadion auf jeden Fall, fand das ganze statt. Da waren vielleicht 200 Leute. Da saßen zwei Journalisten und der eine hatte einen Stift und einen Zettel mit und dann war es das. Es gab keinen Live-Ticker, es gab keine großen Vorberichte, das lief einfach so. In der Zeit ist übrigens viel kaputt gegangen, was diese 50 plus 1 Geschichte angeht. Da wurden Anteile verkauft, Entscheidungen getroffen, das hat überhaupt keiner mitgekriegt. Und in den letzten Jahren nahm das dann so ein bisschen Fahrt auf. Ich glaube, die letzten beiden Jahre haben wir uns in einer der, im Kongresszentrum, in einer der Hallen da getroffen, da waren vielleicht so 800 Leute da. Diesmal hatten wir sogar schon die Swiss Life Hall gemietet, da wird sonst immer Handball gespielt, die Recken aus Hannover spielen da. Also da passen schon ein paar mehr rein. Und ich würde sagen, gestern, wenn man so die Ergebnisse bei den Abstimmungen zählt und dann vielleicht die noch dazurechnet, die nicht abstimmen dürfen, weil sie nicht stimmberechtigt sind, kommen wir so ungefähr auf 1200 Leute, die da insgesamt rumgelaufen sind. Und ja, um das Ergebnis vorwegzunehmen, die waren auch nötig, um allen voran diesen Satzungsänderungsantrag abzubügeln.
Also er wurde abgelehnt im Nachhinein. Kannst du mir mal kurz die Argumentationslinien aufzeichnen, die beide Seiten dann vertreten haben? Also was haben denn dann, du hast ja schon angesprochen, Opposition, schwieriges Wort, aber die beiden Antragsteller, eine Frau, ein Mann. Was waren so die Dinge, die sie vorgebracht haben, warum das eine gute Idee wäre, mehr Kontrolle der Mitglieder über den Vorstand in die Satzung zu schreiben?
Das Mitbestimmungsrecht der Mitglieder. Wir sind ein Verein, so wurde argumentiert. Es sollten doch die Mitglieder am Ende entscheiden über solche wichtigen Dinge, wie zum Beispiel eine Ausliederung bzw. eine Ausnahmegenehmigung von 50 plus 1. Das sind die klassischen Argumente, man will mehr Mitbestimmung, man möchte nicht in einer Vorstandsdiktatur leben, man möchte nicht, dass Entscheidungen getroffen werden, die gegen die Mehrheit der Mitglieder spricht. Das ist ja dann auch tatsächlich das, wenn man auf die letzte Jahreshauptversammlung zurückguckt, da haben 70 Prozent gesagt, ihr sollt uns erst fragen und dann wurden wir nicht gefragt. Das waren die Hauptargumente in der Richtung, das wurde natürlich von vielen Leuten, nicht nur von den Antragstellern, in dieser Aussprache vor der Abstimmung intensiv diskutiert. Man hat da viele Statements gehört, die mehr oder weniger hilfreich waren zur Entscheidungsfindung. Wobei ich davon ausgehe, dass wahrscheinlich 96 Prozent der Anwesenden schon wussten, was sie abstimmen, als sie da hingekommen sind.
96 Prozent ist ja eine witzige Zahl bei Hannover. Die Gegenargumente kann man sich ja aber auch ganz gut herleiten. Man kann ja sagen, haben denn überhaupt die Mitglieder immer den Durchblick oder den Weitblick, vielleicht auch einfach die Kompetenz, um alle Dinge zu entscheiden?
Genau, das ist die eine Geschichte, worauf aber noch viel mehr rumgeritten wurde seitens des Vorstands, ist das Argument Handlungsunfähigkeit. Man hat quasi so ein bisschen herausgestellt, wenn es so kommt, dass wir die Satzungen ändern, dann müssten wir ja bei jedem Kleinkram die Mitglieder fragen. Man hat das von seitens des Vereins sicherlich ein bisschen überspitzt formuliert und ein bisschen überdramatisiert.
Schau dir die SPD an, das hat die an den Rand des Niedergangs gebracht.
Ja, aber Gott sei Dank, also gut. Wir sind Hannover 96, hat Hannover 96 gesagt, und da muss dann der Vorstand auch was entscheiden können. Das war auch schon immer so. Also es war, ja die Argumente, ich will nicht sagen, dass sie ein bisschen dünn waren, aber man hat versucht da diesen Status quo. Wir haben ja so viel erreicht in den letzten 20 Jahren. Wir sind aus der dritten Liga und jetzt sind wir in den letzten 16 Jahren, 15 Jahre dabei und wir haben ein tolles Nachwuchsleistungszentrum und wir haben Stadion und so. Das funktioniert doch so gut. Lasst doch das bitte so, wie es ist. Lasst doch den Vorstand so walten, wie es bisher der Fall war. Da werden insgesamt, das muss ich dazu sagen, werden wirklich viele, viele Sachen durcheinander gemischt, da wird mal was vergessen und dann brüllt auch mal wieder einer rein von der anderen Seite und dann wird auf dieses Argument eingegangen, dann wird auf das nächste Argument nicht eingegangen. Also es ist so eine Jahreshauptversammlung, wie sie im Buche steht, wie man sie sich quasi vorstellt und wie sie, ja, vielleicht bei dem einen oder anderen Verein, der ein oder andere Zuhörer wird es sich denken, auch schon vorgekommen ist. Also das hat Hannover ja auch nicht exklusiv, solche, ja, ein bisschen turbulenten Abende.
Also war die Atmosphäre auch eher hitzig?
Ja, es wurde vor, von allen Seiten appelliert, dass man fair miteinander umgeht, dass man versucht, die ganze Sache respektvoll über die Bühne zu bringen, dass es eine Hannover 96 würdige Veranstaltung ist. Ja, das ist die Frage, ob es dann vielleicht doch Hannover 96 würdig war, obwohl es ein bisschen chaotisch durcheinander war. Es gab immer so hochs und tiefs und ich möchte da gar nicht irgendeine Seite mehr Schuld in die Schuhe schieben als der anderen. Wenn wir jetzt noch mal vielleicht kurz auf diese Geschichte mit der Opposition eingehen. Grundsätzlich stellt man sich ja bei dieser Opposition vor, das sind die Ultras, das ist die aktive Fanszene, das ist die Nordkurve. Ich glaube, so einfach ist es nicht. Natürlich sind da viele dabei, die sich zu den Ultras zählen, die sich zur aktiven Fanszene zählen, aber auch ganz normale Fans, um es jetzt ein bisschen abzugrenzen. Es bleibt dann auch noch so ein bisschen die Frage, ist es überhaupt eine Opposition, wenn man die Mehrheit hat? Also sie haben ja bei fast allen Abstimmungen mehr als 50% gestern Abend gehabt. Sie braucht nur bei dieser wichtigen Abstimmung zwei Drittel und die haben sie nicht erreicht.
Wie viel hat man das verpasst? Wie viel Prozent waren es denn?
Nicht genug. Ich muss ganz kurz gucken in meiner Aufzeichnung. Es waren so viele Zahlen gestern. Man hätte ungefähr 740 Stimmen gebraucht. Es waren 576, also block 160 Stimmen. Das war schon ziemlich deutlich. Ich glaube, wir kamen da auf irgendwas Anfang 50%.
50 plus 1 waren es wahrscheinlich. 50 plus 1 Prozent.
Vielleicht sogar das ja.
Wie wichtig waren denn das alles, was jetzt in den Jahren zuvor schon passiert ist? Jetzt ist es ja so, dass diese Jahreshauptversammlung nicht im lufteren Raum hängt, sondern wir haben einen Stimmungsbacot der Ultras. Wir haben auch erlebt, dass sich zum Teil während Bundesligaspielen andere Teile des Stadions da mit Unmut drüber geäußert haben. Zwischendurch gab es auch wieder Support durch die Fanszene. Es ist unglaublich kompliziert und abwechslungsreich. Hannover Tag & Nacht wird diese Folge heißen. Das habe ich mir diesmal schon vorher überlegt, weil das passt so ein bisschen. Aber wie wichtig waren denn diese Quereen oder Unstimmigkeiten innerhalb der Fanszene jetzt auch für diese Entscheidung? Wurde das häufig thematisiert?
Nein, also das war tatsächlich weniger Thema als gedacht. Es gab die eine oder andere Spitze. Man muss dazu sagen, der Vorstand besteht ja aus mehreren Personen. Es ist nicht nur Martin Kind. Martin Kind hat lediglich gestern den Bericht des Vorstandes vorgetragen, kurz und bündig, relativ unspektakulär und hat sich danach den ganzen Abend aus der Diskussion herausgehalten. Er hat quasi alle Leute so ein bisschen vorgeschickt. Ich gehe davon aus, das war ganz klar eine Taktik von ihm bzw. vom Vorstand. Zumal der Aufsichtsrat, drei von fünf Aufsichtsratsmitglieder sind auch eher Kind sehr wohlgesonnen und auch die haben ihn dann ein Stück weit verteidigt. Es gab vom Vorstand Krause, das ist quasi Kinds Stellvertreter, gab es eine, ja, das war schon nicht schlecht, die Rede. Der hat die Leute heiß gemacht und der hat sie dann auch tatsächlich so ein bisschen auf die Opposition gehetzt bzw. die Opposition in den Dreck gezogen. Das war schon ein knallharter Wahlkampf, der da abgelaufen ist. In dem Zusammenhang wurde dann natürlich auch das Thema, wir sind hier nicht in der Nordkurve, ihr könnt da nicht rumbrüllen und euch daneben benehmen, was halt relativ billige Polemik war, aber er hat es gemacht, wurde dann angesprochen. Ich glaube aber insgesamt, wenn ich mich versuche, an den ganzen Abend zu erinnern, war das Thema ihr boykottiert ja die Mannschaft und ihr singt ja gar nicht mehr und damit schadet ihr dem Verein doch auch, war kein wirkliches Thema an dem Abend.
Finde ich eigentlich sogar überraschend, weil sich ja sogar Horst Heldt innerhalb dieses Jahres sehr, sehr deutlich geäußert hat und im Grunde gesagt hat, ey, es ist egal wie wir spielen, das ist einfach nur gerade alles richtig zum Kotzen hier und er hat sogar noch ein härteres Wort verwendet. Jetzt haben wir auf der einen Seite diesen großen Antrag um Dingsging und auf der anderen Seite hast du mir schon die Information gegeben. Na, es ging nicht so lange wie letztes Jahr, aber fast so lange, also schon über mehrere Stunden. Wie muss ich mir denn jetzt die Jahreshauptversammlung vorstellen? Wenn ich ehrlich bin, kenne ich vor allem diejenigen, das FC Bayern, das kommt immer so Krönungszeremonien gleich mit mehr oder weniger lustigen Wortbeiträgen zwischendurch. Jetzt haben wir schon ein bisschen über die Atmosphäre gesprochen. Wie hat sich denn dieser ganze Abend gestaltet? Wann kam es denn überhaupt zu dieser Abstimmung? Ja, bestimmt nicht als erstes, oder?
Ja, auch das ist eine Geschichte. Wir haben es ja ganz am Anfang angesprochen, dass der Verein natürlich so ein bisschen seine Tricks ausgepackt hat. Unter anderem diese Ticketgeschichte. Die Mannschaft war auch anwesend. Auch das sollte sicherlich den einen oder anderen noch herlocken, der vielleicht mal Salif Saneh oder Philipp Schauner aus der Nähe sehen wollte. Eine dieser Geschichten, die dazugerechnet wird zu diesen Tricks, war die Tagesordnung. Die natürlich vom Vorstand, vom Aufsichtsrat, ich weiß es ja, ich gesagt gar nicht, einer legt es fest, auf jeden Fall...
Glaub, der Aufsichtsrat müsste es eigentlich sein, wenn man da ja was aufversucht....
ist der Aufsichtsratsvorsitzende, der ist eigentlich auch Versammlungsleiter, auch da können wir gleich noch drauf eingehen, dass es dort, ja, dass das nicht alles ganz glücklich gelaufen ist mit dem Versammlungsleiter. Der hat die Tagesordnung festgelegt und dort war eigentlich geplant, dass die Ehrung der langjährigen Mitglieder und die Wahl zum Sportler des Jahres ganz am Ende der Veranstaltung stattfindet. Warum? Damit diese Leute da bleiben. Genau, Max, so sieht es nämlich aus. Und die Opposition, ich nenne sie weiterhin nur Opposition, um es jetzt einfacher zu machen, hat sich natürlich auch ihren Teil dazu gedacht, hat gesagt, halt, wir würden die gerne ändern. Gerade bei der Wahl zum Sportler des Jahres, da sind junge Menschen mit dabei, die noch nicht volljährig sind, die müssen doch auch ins Bett, wenn man das so gut argumentiert, und ob wir es nicht vorziehen können. Wir haben mit einer halben Stunde Verspätung angefangen, wie sich das gehört, für eine ordentliche Jahreshauptersammlung waren nicht alle Leute da, wenn man um 18 Uhr anfängt, kann man das auch noch nicht zwingend erwarten. Wie sich das gehört, ging es dann auch gleich hoch her. Wir haben fast schon gelacht, weil Valentin Schmidt, der Aufsichtsratsvorsitzende, hat gesagt, ja, dann stimmen wir darüber jetzt ab, ob wir die Tagesordnung ändern. Dann hat er gesagt, ja, jetzt heben wir alle kurz hoch hier, die für Änderung sind, und dann heben alle die Karte hoch, die gegen die Änderung sind, und dann hat er gesagt, ja, das habe ich jetzt hier so mit dem Auge grob überblickt, Tagesordnung bleibt.
Das sind ja bayerische Zustände, ist ja furchtbar.
Das sind Dackelzüchterverein-Zustände. Du kannst dir ungefähr vorstellen, was los war in der Halle. Gerade auf Seiten der Opposition gab es laute Zwischenrufe, und Valentin Schmidt hat sich dazu hinreißen lassen, zu sagen, ok, wir zählen das nochmal aus. Das sah dann so aus, dass ich glaube, um die 20 Helfer blockweise gezählt haben, wie viele Leute dagegen gestimmt haben. Und jetzt darfst du dich anschneiden. 462 waren dafür, dass die Tagesordnung beibehalten wird. 581 waren für eine Änderung. Also mal locker 120 Leute mehr.
Das kann man auch nicht sehen.
Das hat er mit seinem professionellen Auge sofort erkannt. Also da war schon gleich ein bisschen Feuer drin. Danach kam diese Rede, wie gesagt, von Vorstand Krause, der da sehr, sehr viel Feuer reingebracht hat, hinten raus gerade noch die Kurve gekriegt hat, um zu sagen, und eigentlich wollen wir doch alle nur das Gleiche. Wir wollen doch alle, dass es Hannover 96 gut geht. Aber vorher hat er erst noch mal die eine oder andere Partei in diesem ganzen Schlamassel in den Dreck gezogen. Das war schon ziemlich schwungvoll. Dann wurde tatsächlich diese Geschichte mit der Wahl vorgezogen. Man hat dann auch die Ehrung der langjährigen Mitglieder. 70 Jahre, unfassbar. Wie lange man in diesem Verein sein kann. Wahnsinn. Die sind dann auch teilweise früher gegangen. Ich habe dann Leute mit Blumensträußen und Flaschen in der Hand gesehen, die deutlich vor der entscheidenden Abstimmung nach Hause gegangen sind. Also da ist der Plan des Vereins nicht aufgegangen, auch wenn es am Ende dann ja doch gereicht hat, was die Stimmen angeht. Das war halt der nette Teil. Die haben die Videos nochmal vorgestellt von den Leuten, die da Sportler des Jahres werden konnten. Und dann wurde da abgestimmt und hinterher wurden Blumen überreicht und alle haben sich gefreut und jeder Teilnehmer hat ein Pokal gekriegt. Wirklich ist nett, ist gar keine Frage. Aber irgendwie, wenn so eine Veranstaltung 5 Stunden dauert, weiß ich immer nicht genau, ob das da am richtigen Platz ist. Wenn man so etwas rauslässt, kann man vielleicht 3,5 zu Ende bringen. Martin Kind hat gesagt, nächstes Jahr machen wir es auf den Samstag.
Bevor ich dich jetzt gleich noch dazu frage, was jetzt dann eigentlich diese Entscheidung mit Hannover 96 wahrscheinlich macht, würde mich interessieren. Auf so einer Jahreshauptversammlung geht es ja um mehr als nur Ehrungen und um irgendwelche Kampfabstimmungen. Es wird ja auch viel berichtet über die aktuelle Situation des Vereins und all seine Unterabteilungen. Wie steht denn Hannover 96 gerade eigentlich da? Den sportlichen Bereich, den sehen wir ja alle. Aber wie sieht es denn zum Beispiel finanziell aus?
Finanziell geht es ja nur tatsächlich um den EV, also um den kleinen Verein. Da reden wir ja nicht von den 70, 80 Millionen Etat, die die Profimannschaft hat. Das ist ja tatsächlich schon ausgebliefert seit vielen, vielen Jahren. Von daher sind das gar nicht so spektakuläre Zahlen. Der Wirtschaftsprüfer, der externe, den man da, glaube ich, für jedes Jahr rangeholt hat, hat gesagt, Hannover geht es gut, es ist genug Geld da. Und wir haben das Jahr 2017 mit insgesamt einem Vereinsergebnis von, und jetzt, pass auf, 40 Euro plus abgeschlossen.
Ja gut, aber wir sprechen ja auch nur über den EV. Und wie haben sich die Mitgliederzahlen entwickelt? Denn da gab es ja auch Geschichten, dass zum Eintritt in den EV aufgerufen wurde. Und dann wurden, ja korrigier mich, wenn es falsch ist, ich glaube ca. 150 Anträge abgelehnt vom Verein. Mit welcher Begründung eigentlich?
Ja, das erwischt mich so fast auf dem falschen Fuß. Also ich glaube es waren 119, die erstmal bekannt waren. Gestern wurde aus dem Plenum der Mitglieder behauptet, es seien auch noch mehr. Das wurde jetzt nicht nachgeprüft. Ich kann es dir auch nicht beantworten, ob es wirklich so ist. Auf jeden Fall wurden da reichlich Mitglieder abgelehnt. Natürlich, weil man davon ausgeht, dass diese zur Opposition zuzurechnen sind. Begründungen braucht man A, keine. Also tatsächlich, dass man einfach ohne Begründung ablehnen kann. Das war aber die letzten 120 Jahre eher nicht der Fall in Hannover. Da hat man aufgenommen, was da war. Das sollte eigentlich auch so sein. Es gibt ja noch Leute, die bringen die Gemeinnützigkeit ins Spiel. Wenn man dann irgendwann anfängt, es auszusortieren, ist man nicht mehr gemeinnützig. Dann möchte ich an dieser Stelle aber jetzt wirklich nicht bewerten, ob das alles juristisch so ganz richtig ist. Ende vom Lied ist, diese Leute wurden nicht aufgenommen. Wenn man sich überlegt, dass die 119 Leute, jeder zahlt 100 Euro im Jahr, sind 11.900 Euro, die aus 40 Euro deutlich mehr hätten machen können, was den Gewinn am Ende war. Ich sag's nur an dieser Stelle.
In der Tat. Und sensationelles Gedächtnis. Ich hab dich da wirklich jetzt so ein bisschen ins kalte Wasser geschmissen und die Zahl stimmt 119 Mitgliedsanträge.
Ich glaube, ich war gestern Abend irgendwo und jemand meinte, es seien sogar noch mehr erkennende Leute, die nicht aufgenommen wurden. Keine Ahnung. Es wurden da, vielleicht das noch als Ergänzung für die Leute, die da nicht so tief drinstecken, es wurden tatsächlich Aufnahmegespräche teilweise geführt.
Wie hat sich denn die Mitgliederzahl dann entwickelt?
Genau, das wollte ich noch zu Ende bringen. Auch da gibt es jetzt eine Zahl, die vom Verein rausgegeben wurde, die natürlich so präsentiert wird, dass sie sicherlich ganz gut aussieht. Von 2012 bis 2017 gibt es bei den Fördermitgliedern und bei den passiven Mitgliedern, also das ist letztendlich alles das, was nicht selber Sport bei Hannover 96 treibt, 27,8% Zuwachs und insgesamt 40% Zuwachs. Das heißt, bei den aktiven Mitgliedern ist es noch deutlich mehr an Leuten, die da mitmachen. Liegt auch daran, dass wir neue Sparten aufgemacht haben, dass wir teilweise andere Vereine oder andere Sparten aus anderen Vereinen sind bei uns mit aufgegangen. Es ist ein großes Hin und Her. Der größte Teil ist, glaube ich, die Abteilung Fit & Kids. Da kann man dann als junger Mensch viel Sport treiben. Und das machen wir uns nichts vor. Neben den großen Einnahmeposten aus den Fördermitgliedern, da reden wir von 870.000 Euro, die da jedes Jahr an Hannover 96 fließen, ist diese Fit & Kids-Abteilung wirklich nicht zu unterschätzen. Ich glaube, die sind danach die größten.
Ja, genau. Da kommt auch viele, viele Leutearbeiten da, wenn man sich mal ein bisschen auf eurer Homepage durchklickt. Aber jetzt lass mal dann auch über die KGAA sprechen, also über die Fußball-Abteilung von der Hannover 96.
Lass uns ganz kurz einen wichtigen Aspekt sprechen, der gestern Abend hier definitiv nicht untergehen sollte. Das ist die sonst eigentlich immer recht unspektakuläre Entlastung des Vorstandes und des Aufsichtsrates. Das passiert eigentlich immer mehr oder weniger knapp und es ist dann durch. Tatsächlich war es gestern so, dass sowohl der Vorstand als auch der Aufsichtsrat nicht entlastet wurden. Ganz panische Zustände auf der Presse-Tribüne. Google wurde angeschmissen.
Was heißt das eigentlich?
Tatsächlich, auf der ersten Seite, wenn man das googelt, findet man aus dem Kölner Stadtanzeiger eine Nachricht aus 2010. Ich gehe mal davon aus, beim FC war es dann 2010 auch mal so, dass der Vorstand nicht entlastet wurde. Hat an, soweit ich das auf die Stelle erfassen konnte, gar nicht so große Auswirkungen. Es geht da letzten Endes nur darum, dass der Vorstand bzw. der Aufsichtsrat von der Haftung nicht entbunden werden. Man möge mich gerne korrigieren, so habe ich das erstmal verstanden. Grundsätzlich können sie natürlich ganz normal weiterarbeiten in ihrer Legislaturperiode und das tun sie natürlich auch. Denn, und jetzt kommen wir zu dem spannenden Punkt, auch wenn Martin Kind als Vorstand nicht entlastet wurde, hat er hinterher gesagt, das ist erst einmal unbedeutend, maximal optisch interessant, aber inhaltlich letztlich ohne Bedeutung. Also so ist Martin Kind, der sieht das Positive am gestrigen Abend, der sagt, der Satzungsänderungsantrag ist nicht durchgekommen. Ist doch egal, ob ich entlastet werde oder nicht.
Also das heißt, wir können mal so ein bisschen zusammenfassen. Was passiert ist, war, dass man zum wiederholten Male gesehen hat, dass eine Mehrheit der Mitglieder gegen das ist, was Martin Kind anstrebt, nämlich die völlige Befugnisgewalt über Hannover 96 zu haben. Und dass es aber auch nicht zu irgendwelchen juristisch bindenden Satzungsänderungen für ihn gekommen ist. Und Martin Kind deswegen, er hätte es vielleicht auch so ignoriert, hatte er im letzten Jahr auch schon. Aber er hat im Grunde auch nichts, woran er sich jetzt halten muss. So kann man doch das jetzt zusammenfassen, was passiert ist auf der Hauptversammlung.
Genau, so kann man es zusammenfassen. Man muss vielleicht noch dazu sagen, dass diese Satzung erst vor zwei Jahren, 2016, quasi komplett neu geschrieben wurde. Und dass bei dieser Neuschreibung auch Vertreter aus der Opposition mit dabei waren, die das genauso wollten und dann auch empfohlen haben, diese Satzung so anzunehmen. Die wurde damals mit ganz großer Mehrheit, ich glaube sogar 100% angenommen. Also vielleicht hat man damals nicht genau erkannt, welche sich da so hinter der ganzen Geschichte verbirgen. Und jetzt hast du halt das Problem, in Anführungsstrichen, dass du zwei Drittel der Mitglieder brauchst, um die Satzung zu ändern. Und das ist zum zweiten Mal in Folge relativ deutlich. Dieses Jahr, letztes Jahr war es glaube ich ein bisschen knapper, hat es nicht funktioniert. Und ja, die Konsequenz ist, Martin Kind bleibt König von Hannover, zumindest Vorstand vom EV, kann schalten und walten, wie er möchte, da der Aufsichtsrat aktuell noch mit drei Leuten besetzt ist, die ihm keine Steine in den Weg legen. Und ja, mal gucken, was er in den nächsten zwölf Monaten so macht. Denn nächstes Jahr ist Aufsichtsratwahl, da könnte das dann vielleicht noch mal kippen.
Das wäre jetzt auch so ein bisschen meine Frage gewesen, wieso die Zukunft von Hannover 96 aussieht. Was glaubst du, wird jetzt im nächsten Jahr passieren? Das ist ein bisschen gemein, denn es passiert bei euch immer sehr, sehr viel. Und das hier ist ja ein Kurzpass. Aber kann man da schon Tendenzen ausmachen? Hat sich Martin Kind noch mal geäußert, wird er zum Beispiel gegen 50 plus 1 vor Gericht ziehen, so wie er es ja mehrfach angedeutet hat? Wie wird sich das entwickeln, deiner Meinung nach?
Also gelesen habe ich tatsächlich heute auch ein paar Sachen drüber. Und es gibt den einen oder anderen, der der Meinung ist, jetzt wird Kind richtig Gas geben, jetzt wird er den Antrag, der ja aktuell ruhend gestellt ist, wird er wieder aktiv stellen, beziehungsweise für Notfall dann auch den Klageweg eingehen. Ich bin mir da noch gar nicht so ganz sicher. Es gibt nicht wenige Leute, die sagen, dieser Antrag wird krachend abgelehnt von der DFL, weil Martin Kind einfach diese Voraussetzungen nicht erfüllt.
Also es geht quasi darum, dass er nachweist, dass er schon 20 Jahre oder mehr zum wesentlichen Teil für Hannover 96 finanziell aufgekommen ist. Und unter dieser Ausnahme, das ist dann die Dietmar-Hop-Regelung, die damals bei 50 plus 1 eingeführt wurde, könne er dann eben Entscheidungsbefugnis beim Verein haben. Das habe ich doch so richtig zusammengefasst.
Du hast das richtig verstanden und du hast dir gerade zwei Sachen mit reingebracht. Einmal die erhebliche Förderung, die finanzielle Förderung, und 20 Jahre ununterbrochen. Die erhebliche Förderung ist wohl tatsächlich ein bisschen problematisch, dass man als vergleichswert das sagt, was der Hauptsponsor abbringt, und das auf die 20 Jahre, und das müsste Kind ungefähr auch geleistet haben. Da aber wohl, das ist alles Vermutung, da weder der Antrag auf Erteilung dieser Ausnahmegenehmigung, noch dieses geheime Papier von der DFL öffentlich bekannt sind. Es gibt Menschen, die sagen, sie hätten da schon reingeguckt. Es ist aber nicht öffentlich bekannt. Ist das alles so ein bisschen Stoch an dem Nebel, was die ganze Geschichte angeht. Was aber tatsächlich Hannover 96 gestern bestätigt hat, und das war so eine Randnotiz, die fast nirgends größer aufgegriffen wurde, ist die Geschichte mit der 20 Jahre ununterbrochene Förderung. Hoch, sondern dass er überhaupt das getan hat. Denn es gab vier Informationsanträge. Ein Informationsantrag hatte die Frage, ich lese das jetzt einfach kurz vor, es ist nicht lang, ist es richtig, dass der ehemalige Präsident, Herr Götz von Fromberg, der war in der Zeit Präsident, als Martin Kind nicht da war, schriftlich bestätigt hat, dass während seiner Präsidentschaft zwischen August 2005 und Juli 2006, also ein Jahr, keine Entscheidung ohne Herrn Martin Kind im Hannoverischen Sportverein stattgefunden hat. Antwort dazu ist, es ist nicht richtig, dass Herr Kind in der genannten Phase, in der er keine Funktion beim Hannoverischen Sportverein hatte, auf irgendwelche Entscheidungen Einfluss genommen hat. Es wurden keine Entscheidungen durch Martin Kind während dieser Zeit getroffen. Deshalb war es auch nicht notwendig, dass dies vom Vorstand oder Aufsichtsrat unterbunden wird. So, ein Jahr hat Martin Kind nichts zu sagen gehabt. Und damit fallen für mich zumindest die 20 Jahre erst mal komplett raus. Sie wackeln sehr stark, ich weiß es nicht genau.
Aber geht es da um Entscheidungen, geht es da nicht um Förderung? Weil wenn er in diesem Jahr trotzdem einen Millionenbetrag in den Verein gesteckt hätte, dann...
Das hat er ja wohl auch nicht. Er hat wohl in diesem Posten, was hat er in den Verein gesteckt, allen voran seine Tätigkeit, seine unentgeltliche Tätigkeit als Präsident angerechnet. Wo er dann gesagt hat, jeden Tag so und so viele Stunden, und das habe ich mir nicht bezahlen lassen, also hat der Verein davon profitiert in x Millionen Höhe.
Ja, das ist natürlich stark. Da muss man eine Germanistik-Fachschaft übernehmen können.
Der Antrag ist nicht bekannt. Selbst unser Aufsichtsrat, der den Antrag durchgewunken hat, kennt den Antrag nicht, so wie sich gestern herausgestellt hat. Max, du musstest dir alles nur vorstellen, wie es in der Welt war.
Ich kann es mir ja nicht vorstellen. Deswegen brauche ich Leute wie dich, ganz dringend, die mir das erklären, weil es auch einfach sehr undurchsichtig ist. Und weil ich auch die Erfahrung gemacht habe, da darfst du mich jetzt gerne korrigieren, wenn ich falsch liege, aber ich verlasse mich nicht mehr auf die überregional bekannten Hannover-Rahner Medien. Da stehen immer wieder interessante Details drin, aber ich habe gerade in Gesprächen mit dir und auch mit anderen Hannover 96 Fans immer wieder Dinge erfahren, wo ich mir dachte, sei interessant, dieser Aspekt stand in keinem Artikel, den ich zum Thema gelesen habe. Also ich habe den Eindruck, dass man da auch wirklich tief in der Materie und nah dran sein muss, damit man das ganze Bild sehen kann, weil nicht alle Parteien, die da mit involviert sind, immer das ganze Bild abbilden.
Also ich würde schon behaupten, dass alle Fakten hier in der ansässigen, also vielleicht nicht zwingend bei der Bild-Zeitung, die verkürzen ja auch gerne Grundsätze.
Ja, das meine ich ja nicht.
Die anderen beiden, die Hannover Schallgemeine Zeitung und die Neue Presse, möchte ich schon behaupten, dass alle Fakten irgendwann mal genannt wurden. Es wurde auch im Vorfeld dieser Jahreshauptversammlung die Opposition ziemlich intensiv präsentiert. Es wurden Interviews geführt, die hatten die Möglichkeit, sich auf großen Seiten ihre Wünsche und ihren Antrag vorzustellen. Aber, und da mit der Meinung wirst du wahrscheinlich nicht alleine sein, und ich bin es wahrscheinlich auch nicht, es geht immer so ein bisschen um die Gewichtung. Und da gibt es sicherlich den einen oder anderen Artikel, der öfter oder ein oder anderer Fakt, der öfter präsentiert wird als der andere. Aber ich glaube, es wird nichts verschwiegen, du musst es nur suchen. Natürlich als Auswertling ist das natürlich wieder schwierig, da jeden Tag jeden kleinen Artikel zu lesen.
Gute und richtige Einschränkungen. Vielleicht hat es sich da auch ein bisschen gewandelt. Ich habe vor allem viel Informationen gesucht, zu dem, wie es damals zustande kam, dass Martin Kind für einen relativ niedrigen Teil sich Anteile an Hannover 96 erworben hat. Und da ist mir aufgefallen, dass die Informationslage für die Bedeutung dieser Entscheidung ganz schön dünn war. Und da habe ich dann aber angefangen, mit Leuten zu reden. Wir haben da ja auch, ich glaube, auch im Rasenfunk irgendwann schon mal drüber gesprochen. Und da habe ich dann viele Dinge erfahren, wo ich mir dachte, ach, interessant, das konnte ich mir jetzt gar nicht ergugeln. Aber das kann ja auch an ganz vielen Dingen liegen. Abschließende Frage an dich hätte ich noch. Gerade aus Sicht derjenigen, die dieser ganze Entwicklung äußerst kritisch gegenüberstehen. Ich denke, ich spreche hier für Teile der Ultras und vielleicht auch andere Fans, die jetzt auch schon eigentlich alle Register gezogen haben. Man hat Satzungsänderungen probiert, man hat Stimmungsboikotte probiert, man hat versucht, national für Aufmerksamkeit zu sorgen für diese Thematik. Glaubst du, diese Leute kommen irgendwann an einen Punkt, wo sie sagen, okay, es reicht, wir verabschieden uns einfach von diesem Verein und, ja, was auch immer, gründen einen anderen Hannover-Rana-Verein oder gehen zu anderen Vereinen? Könnte das jetzt passieren?
Also dafür stecke ich tatsächlich nicht tief genug in der aktiven Fanszene drin, um das beurteilen zu können. Es beeindruckt mich ein Stück weit, mit welcher Hartnäckigkeit aktuell dieser Boykott durchgezogen wird. Ich glaube, ich bin fest davon überzeugt, dass es denen selber auch keinen Spaß macht. Ich saß gegen Dortmund, als wir 4 zu 2 zu Hause gewonnen haben. Da war Boykott, saß ich in der Nähe unseres harten Kerns in der Mitte. Als das 4 zu 2 gefallen ist, die waren hin und hergerissen zwischen ich raste hier komplett aus vor Freude und eigentlich wollen wir keine Stimmung machen.
Mein Gott, das ist ja wie der Videobeweis, der alle Emotionen tötet. Sehr fürchterlich.
Da macht man einen Videobeweis an alle Emotionen.
Ja genau, wo man nicht weiß, ob man jubeln darf.
Viele Leute finden das schon alles sehr schwer. Kann mir aber auch durchaus vorstellen, ich kenne tatsächlich auch persönlich Leute, die jetzt vielleicht nicht vor zu den Ultras zu zählen waren, aber schon in die Richtung aktive Fernszene gehen, die sich nach und nach Stück für Stück, und das ist ein Prozess, der jetzt nicht erst in den letzten 6 Monaten oder 12 Monaten passiert ist, sondern tatsächlich schon über Jahre hinweg vom Verein von Hannover 96, entfernt haben, die auch tatsächlich Dauerkarten nicht mehr nutzen, die nicht mehr ins Stadion gehen, die nicht mehr auswärts fahren. Das gibt es, ich kann dir aber quantitativ nicht sagen, sind das 2%, 5%, 0,2%, ich weiß es nicht, keine Ahnung. Die Zuschauerzahlen sind wie jedes Jahr bei uns, gegen Bern und Bremen und Hamburg ist es voll, gegen Augsburg und Hoffenheim auf den Dienstagabend. Hast du noch ein bisschen Platz um dich rum, sag ich mal.
Ja gut, dass man es nicht genau weiß, ist ja auch eine ausreichende Antwort auf diese Frage. Zumindest bahnt sich da kein großer Knall an. Das ist doch dann interessant zu wissen. Tobi, Tobi, vielen, vielen Dank dir. Noch viel ausführlicher kann man das alles hören bei Hannoverliebt. Da nehmt ihr jetzt dann auch noch eine Folge auf. Die wird wahrscheinlich auch heute erscheinen, am Freitag?
Mal gucken, ausführlicher, ja. Vielleicht gehen wir einfach von einem anderen Kenntnisstand aus.
Okay, also hört euch auch das an, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Tobi, vielen Dank dir.